Paul yeah let's get into it so this is
about cultivating creativity and I love
to start with this quote because I think
and I'm going to focus primarily on
cultivating individual creativity how
you change yourself and you know maybe
not turn yourself into a creative person
but realize more about the creative
person that you already are there are
some analogies to personal creativity
and organizational creativity you can
apply these same principles to groups
but I'm going to talk primarily about
the individual and we can talk about how
you apply it later when we get to
questions but so that I start with this
quote the real voyage of discovery lies
not in seeking new landscapes but in
having new eyes so we're you know we're
committed to the notion that everybody
is individually creative some people may
have a natural ability to manifest that
creativity easily others it may may not
feel they have that but we know from our
work with thousands and thousands of
students that we can awaken creativity
in almost any any individual and that
comes to the thing that really is the
foundation for the the d.school we call
it and this notion of Design Thinking
David Kelley is the founder of IDEO and
also the founder of D school that and as
senior faculty here now for almost 40
years you know said that Design Thinking
is a sense that its core Design Thinking
is all about unlocking potential and
creating creative confidence in our
students and we've been doing this in
the design program since 1963
and we've been doing it the d.school
since 2005 this notion of taking the
methodologies that were originally
developed in the fields of product
design and service design but applying
them to a larger issue of organizations
strategy and in our case today personal
creativity David's got a great TED talk
that you can refer to if you're
interested
seeing him present the information and
then just recently and I think maybe six
months ago the David and his brother Tom
who also works at IDEO created their a
book on this subject called creative
confidence unleashing the creative
potential within all of us and we like
this idea of creative confidence like
that you would feel that you have the
ability to solve problems think outside
of the box and do things in a in the
creative realm that and maybe in the
past you thought only artists or
designers or whatever whoever you
thought creative people were only they
could do these things and it turns out
that that's not true we have tons and
tons of evidence both from the field of
psychology and from the field of design
and certainly from our own educational
offerings here at Stanford in the
d.school
that we can turn on the creative
confidence in almost anyone so just to
give you a little bit of background on
this notion of Design Thinking you know
we've been teaching design for a long
time here at Stanford but we were very
interested in kind of how did how could
you teach this this methodology this
idea of thinking like a designer to
anyone because everybody's got to solve
problems
everybody's got a you know some problems
in their daily life some problems in the
organization and so in the early part of
2004 2005 the faculty so took a step
backwards and said what is this really
all about what makes the process of
thinking like a designer to solve a
problem different from say the process
of thinking like an engineer or I think
like a business person and we extracted
these principles the Design Thinking is
both the process and some and kind of a
way of thinking so the process is quite
simple we don't start with a problem we
start with a person we don't start with
let's go design a new wheel barrow we
start with you know stepping back and
trying to look at the whole issue of you
know in case of wheelbarrows you know
construction folks on a jobsite who need
to have materials when they need them
and what's that all about and so we go
out and we start with
we do a deep dive on the human situation
and develop even before we've developed
the hypothesis or the question we're
trying to solve we we take whatever the
focal question is at the start pretty
much throw it away and just go talk to
the people who are involved in the
problem and then we define or really
redefine the problem which is where we
have a big you know kind of a bunch of
tools about reframing problems most of
the time I find in my own consulting
practice in practice with companies to
come to Stanford they say hey we want to
we want to we want to get out of the box
and we want to think really big ly and
big and then the problem they present
there's actually a solution you know how
do we design better wheelbarrows
wheelbarrows a solution about a not a
problem so we do a redefine and then we
do a lot of stuff in the ideation part
of the project and we're going to hit on
one topic here in ideation because it's
the thing people say they do but they
don't really do well but having lots of
ideas if you have lots of ideas you can
choose from a much better pool of ideas
and then our process is essentially a
prototype and test prototype and test
process and the prototyping and this and
this design thinking framework isn't
this it's a we're using the term very
specifically not the generic notion of
building a model of something you know
that you wanted that you want to produce
because we can present have an
experience we can prototype service we
can present a product we can prototype
strategy but it's not to be a solution
is to be a good question and then we got
tests with the people that we had
empathy for so it's it's a very
interesting process it's not this linear
of course we can start at any part of
the process we can you know and we loop
back often after we built some things
and try them with people we loop back
and realize our original definition was
incorrect or it's not quite precise and
so a feature of Design Thinking is that
we know we don't know and so we start
with people we redefine problems and
then we have this highly circular
process of sort of building our way
forward into so
the former president of Ford Allen
Millay he used to say culture eats
processed for lunch you can have any
kind of process you want but if you
don't have a design thinking or a
creative culture the processes won't
result in innovative solutions and so we
really think you and if you don't think
about our design process starting with
empathy in any way you know prototyping
think about our mindsets the mindsets of
radical collaboration great ideas come
from groups of people who do not share
common backgrounds they're not it's not
just a radical collaboration it's not
getting six engineers from six different
divisions together because that's all
engineering thinking it's truly a
radical collaboration of people from all
over the organization reframing problems
really design thinking at its most
powerful it's about problem finding not
about problem solving and so the ability
to look at problems in a unique way and
having methods to do that is critical
mindfully process because as I said this
you know we don't you can start anywhere
in that process diagram and sometimes it
gets very confusing and you're not sure
exactly what you're where you are in the
process of resolving a problem or
designing a new thing and so it's good
to be going back constantly and checking
to see that you know you're staying in
the process of creativity a bias to
action we don't spend a lot of time
doing analysis we'll build prototypes
you know long before most organizations
would even think you know that they're
ready we don't do a lot of specification
market requirements documents and things
like that this is again an idea finding
problem finding you know phase of a
program and we tend to build to think so
the big bias to action it all comes from
this we're deeply curious about the
people we're designing for in the case
of ourselves and trying to make
ourselves more creative I think it's
easy to be deeply curious about how your
brain works and how you get stuck and
where you where you might be able to
move forward in a more creative way if
you just had a slightly different
framework to work inside of and so we're
going to apply Design Thinking now to
ourselves and talk
personal creativity where so we're in
the id8 bubble are the idea of hexagon
of this process and we're talking about
this this notion of creativity personal
creativity and you know a lot of times
when people come to me they just say I'm
not creative you know I was never one of
the creative kids in high school I
didn't take our tour I wasn't a musician
and they kind of attach creativity to
some special trade or talent that they
think they don't have and they've turned
creativity into some kind of a problem
I'd like to unpack that and probably
resolve that if I can for you right now
so this isn't a poll you can sort of
silently ask yourself gee was I'm more
creative when I was a child
think to yourself back when you're six
or seven you know
first grade preschool first grade and
you're playing on the playground and you
could turn a stick into a rocket ship
and you could turn a rock into a castle
and you I mean you had this ability to
just imagine a world in a very
open-ended and creative way and most
people when I talk in the class about
this they say yeah you know there was
something and then talk about curiosity
I was curious about everything I had a
really open and engaged way of being in
the world
I'm whether you were an extrovert or and
in terms a big introvert as a child but
I could play you know by myself with
just objects I found in the world and
turned them into you know complete
environments so most people think they
were this way and the question is why
well you know if you were that sort of a
creative child what happened and and
here's what happened first education
which wish D values creativity and
overvalues kind of command and control
most schools are designed around
controlling kids not educating their
creative processes because creative kids
do things that don't follow the rules
and therefore you learn pretty quickly
as soon as you started engaging
institutions that being different or
great daydreaming or or imagined
things that weren't on the schedule of
the teacher were really not received in
a very positive way and the other thing
that was true is that as as as humans
evolved there's this notion of neural
Darwinism which is the idea that the
brain has evolved through resource
competition to operate you know in the
body competing for energy from all the
other body bodily systems so you consume
about 2,000 calories a day roughly the
average human a 2,000 calories that's
the energy input it turns out your brain
takes 500 of those calories 25% of the
energy you consume every day just goes
to running your brain which is a huge
amount the brain is only 2% of your body
mass and it's consuming 25% of the
energy so if it's consumed probably any
more energy than that it would you know
then the rest of the body couldn't
function so over time you're evolved is
very efficient but very power hungry
brain the brain operates on about 40
ones which I always found it to be a
startling statistic because you know
your lap your modern laptop is about 80
or a hundred watts and you know if
you've got a reasonable desktop
computers 4 or 500 watts and Watson the
computer that won the Jeopardy challenge
is 250,000 watts and Watson can't write
a poem and it can't fall in love and it
can't paint a painting I mean it's just
a you know my favorite Picasso quote as
computers are useless because all they
can give you our answers and your brain
is such amazing mechanism for asking
these interesting questions but it has
to compete for energy with the rest of
the body so it has evolved to be one of
the most efficient processors on the
planet we have no idea how to build a 40
watt processor we have no idea how to
build a processor that can do what the
brain does
in general but we're off by a hundred
orders of magnitude in terms of the
efficiency of the brain now that
efficiency comes with a couple of
problems one of the problems is the
brain can't respond to all of the
stimulus that are seeing all of the time
in still operating 40 watts so this is a
model of the brain
name comes from Donald Arman and Dan
Goleman the dense the emotional
intelligence guy Don Norman's a
cognitive psychologist who's also
written a bunch on design but this is
why your this is the box and this is why
you're in the box you've got everybody
kind of things well I see the whole
world and then I process everything and
then I do what I do I have some
unconscious responses and conscious
responses and that's the whole thing but
it turns out it's not nothing like that
at all the way we have now mapped the
way the brain processes information is
that you you know the your eyes your
ears your your physical body you know
kinesthetic knowledge the visual
knowledge the auditory stuff that's
coming in that all gets sort of censored
a little bit it gets filtered into
things that the brain can process and
then instead of thrown up into you know
the unconscious processing of the brain
and into short and long term memory and
everything is organized into simple
schemas you know there's this notion
that there's a grandmother neuron that
one neuron fires when you see your
grandmother it's not quite true but it's
kind of true you know when you see
people that you don't know you have to
process lots of information about their
faces but your best friend your mom
somebody that you've seen hundreds of
times really only activates a small
number of neural paths to provide the
recognition so the brain rapidly
schematize is data and that's so that it
can process information is the lowest
possible energy state and what you're
actually aware of turns out to be one
one hundred thousandth of the data
that's being processed and it's actually
organized for you in this little little
part of the brain that's called pre
consciousness or preconscious prediction
and that part of the brain is what
you're actually conscious of you're
conscious of all the things that you see
but they've been schema ties into very
simple formats and you're conscious of
what you think is going to come next so
it turns out I know if you're seeing the
video of there's a video that sort of
demonstrates how attention filters
information it's a video that's open up
the internet you can find it some a
bunch of people you're asked to count
the people passing basketballs and
there's a white team and a black team
and you count the basketball passes of
the white team and if you pay it real
attention to that you can actually
figure it out they're moving around a
lot it's kind of complicated but it's I
think that's 36 passes is the right
number but while attending to that you'd
fail to notice that a man in a gorilla
suit has walked across the middle of the
of the video waved at the camera and
walked away about 50 or 60 percent of
the people who concentrate on the video
and get the correct answer do not see
the gorilla and that's because our
information systems are chunking things
down into schemas and only looking at
what we think is going to happen or what
we've been asked to observe and so the
psychologists have come up with this
notion that we don't really see what
we're looking at it's all the data is
all there it's an unconscious processing
but we only are aware of that we only
see what we're looking for then the
other interesting piece of data about
your brain is the consciousness this
awareness that we have that attends to
things it's really only 300 minutes less
than a half a second we know this
because we've mapped some short and long
term memories the two processes that
allow us to construct the world and
there have been people who have had
unfortunately a brain tumor or a lesion
or some kind of a surgery which has
disconnected their long term memory
functions and they only have about a
seven or eight minute awareness of the
world that's as long as their world
lasts there was a pretty famous movie
called memento
about a guy who had this condition and
so unfortunately there's also been
people who have lost about their long
and short-term memory and we know that
their ability to you know kind of
process and remember things this pure
consciousness is less than a half a
second so why am I telling you this well
because what it turns out then is that
although we think we have this direct
view of objective reality the truth is
that we're putting reality together
almost like the frames of a movie little
300-millisecond frames Torrent tossed
into short-term memory schematized and
then repeated back to us so that we know
what to look for the things that are
important but the things that our brain
has told us to look for are just the
things that we expect to see
and so we're kind of making up a video
game here and it's it's sort of some
ways a little depressing to think that
I'm not actually seeing the whole world
and that my my perceptions are highly
filtered and that I'm really only seeing
what I'm looking for but actually
there's a positive and all that let me
take you to one more piece of data and
then we'll pull it all together
there are tests that you can that the
psychologists have sort of validated the
demonstrate sort of a natural creativity
in people and research on people who
rate high on these tests highly creative
people reveals that they have three
completely different three things that
are different about them and this is
different in the sense that we put them
in an fMRI scanner we're scanning their
brains we're asking them to do creative
tasks they're completing those tasks
then we take quote normals and we scan
their brains we say what's the
difference what's what's going on in the
brain that's different research and
creative people reveals three things one
they actually perceive the world
differently when when shown visual
things are given tactile things to touch
their brain lights up in a much more
holistic way the left and right brain is
more active than in a normal person a
normal normal person versus creative
person they also have a high social
awareness response they have a high
empathy response now often times very
creative people are introverts think of
artists and scientists and and you know
computer programmers who are said to be
very creative at the top of their field
it's oftentimes introvert so this is not
an introvert extrovert thing this is
just so they have a real sort of a extra
emotional response to the world and the
third thing is they have what's called
with the college is called a low fear
response to novelty this is by the way
from a book by Gregory Berns
on neuroscience and creativity this low
fear response to novelty is really
interesting because what it is is that
when shown something that should because
it's new and it's different should
because your amygdala to light up and
some some stress hormones to flow it
doesn't happen
they it's actually actually a part of
their brain that does not function
correctly and fee response the novelty
is is necessary evolution would probably
design it in to our two individuals and
two groups because if you're afraid of
appropriately afraid of things to jump
out at you in the forest and you don't
know what they are then you won't get
eaten and if we are all afraid of the
same things we're a more cohesive tribe
and so we stayed together so creativity
would have been you know sort of bred
out in an evolutionary sense except that
it's important to have a few people left
in the tribe were creative because when
the situation's change they can respond
in a creative manner and this is the
basis of really of David's book that low
fear response to novelty can be learned
Albert bandura when psychologists here
in Stanford studied phobias people who
are terrified of snakes are terrified of
spiders or terrified of flying and
developed a protocol she called guided
mastery which allowed people to move
away from these fear responses and
actually master them so they could
actually pick up a snake or hold a
spider in their hand or get on an
airplane and when put it back in a brain
scanner had no no fear response so it's
a it's a set of neural paths that you
can train and that's the great news that
one you can learn this and the two you
can take advantage of the Box we're in a
box it's true we have these schematic
ways of thinking we only see what we're
looking for
but that's that's I would argue this the
liberating idea everybody's in a box so
don't feel bad there's nothing wrong
with you your brain works just like
everybody else to drain creativity is
probably a brain deficit it's not
something special that you weren't that
you were born with and you have this
extra part of your brain is actually
something that doesn't work and you know
how to turn off the part of your brain
that works well so that's a good that's
that's good news
creativity is a very high energy brain
behavior brains like to operate at 40 or
20 or 10 watts if they can it's not
normal but you can train your brain to
do these kinds of behaviors and so these
things can be learned and if you it's
just three things in personal creativity
low learn to lower your fear of failure
learn to lower the fear of the novel
because if you want to do something
unusual and creative it will by
definition be scary learn since your
brain manipulates your attention through
the schematic mechanism learn to
manipulate the schemas that's why we
often in brainstorming sessions say
something like what if you were an
elephant how would you solve this
problem what if there were no gravity
how would you solve this problem all
we're doing is changing what's in your
preconscious lauder to predict what's
coming next we're asking for unusual
predictions but you can train yourself
to change the way you look for
information and you can access your
other intelligences there's emotional
intelligence kinesthetic intelligence
and I'm going to talk specifically about
the sort of what I'm coming I call
improvisational intelligence the ability
to create in the moment
okay so all these things are learn about
and and they learn about with the brain
you've got you didn't nothing wrong with
what you got so we're talking about
ideation
first rule train yourself to get stuck
sounds kind of funny like why would I
want to get stuck I want to be more
creative I don't want to be stuck but if
you got to learn to be stuck if you want
to learn to have the aha moment doubt
how moment that comes right after being
stuck Paul mentioned that we did a
workshop down in Mexico and it was
actually for a bunch of financial
services executives and one of the
bankers came up to me halfway through
the workshop and said you know I hear
all you I hear what you're saying and it
all sounds really good he's just but I'm
not creative I said we're creative he
says well because I just get stuck I got
stuck on the first problem and then I
couldn't solve it I get stuck on the
second problem and I said well then
stuck it's not the problem I get stuck
all the time I mean designers take on
problems they never I get stuck ten
times a day so getting stock isn't the
issue it's about how do you get unstuck
right there's an exercise in Jim Adams
conceptual blockbusting that I use a lot
called 30 circles and it's a wonderful
little exercise you basically just put
30 circles on a page and try to make the
circles into something that's all the
instructions and people make up their
own rules and they get stuck and they
run out of ideas and they have all these
sort of you know coping behaviors when
they feel bad about themselves and we're
able to walk them through that process
and almost everybody goes from being
stuck and then having a little ha moment
where they realized a new way to solve
the problem and so if we can if you can
train yourself to notice when you're
stuck and then use the methods that Jim
talks about in his book about how you
get unstuck you can contribute sensual
box demonstrate how we make up our own
rules most of the rules that you're
operating under are not real you made
them up they're not actually even in the
problem they're just in your brain and
at by practicing this over and over and
over again with a series of exercises
like 30 circles you build the neural
connections that seek the aha moment
because the aha moment versus the stuck
mom is terrible you feel bad you just
want to stop working on the problem and
go wash your cat or something I mean
anything looks better than being stuck
but the the aha moment when you have a
good idea that's a completely different
moment when you're in a brain scanner we
see you know you're multi regions of
your brain light up we see endorphins
being really
which are happy chemicals you know the
stress hormones are dropping endorphins
and happy chemicals are rising and you
have massively engaged brain activity
very high energy brain activity at feels
so good that it's the incentive to get
stuck because a ha moment can only come
after the stuck moment so if you if you
teach your challenge yourself with hard
problems problems that you don't know
the answers to and Trott challenges up
over and over and over again as you have
these moments these aha moments you're
going to get and get hooked on the happy
chemicals and you're going to want to
have more and more of them but you can't
get there until you get stuck and a lot
of times people don't know what they're
stuck state feels like they have been
working on problems for so long within
such a sort of non generative way that
it's just you know they try to avoid
problems that cause that brain behavior
I'm going to argue go the other way
get stuck a lot get stuck ten times a
day and get unstuck you know as many
times as you can
more often than not you're just trying
to get a lower your fear of failure and
and so embracing that if you're going to
be a creative person you have to act
like one a creative person acts like a
curious person and take some problems
that they don't know how to solve
number two teach yourself to brainstorm
everybody does brainstorming and most
people do sort of a truncated version of
it I'm going to argue that brainstorming
you should when you're brainstorming
think of yourself as like a fantastic
jazz musician if you think about what a
brainstorm is figure four people in a
room trying to come up with ideas but
none of them have ever thought of before
it's exactly like a jazz combo you end
and you got to practice this because it
makes no more sense to sit in - you know
you wouldn't sit in with the Miles Davis
sex tab but these fantastic jazz players
if you didn't know how to play a
saxophone or you know how to play the
drums but what I see over and over again
is people sitting down ad hoc with
people who've never brainstormed before
they don't follow the rules they don't
frame a good question they don't warm up
first they don't do any of the
activities that we we teach and then
they say see the brainstorm didn't work
it's like well you know and you wouldn't
play very much jazz if you'd never
picked up a saxophone before so the
mechanics of this are really rather
difficult and even when you get very
good at the mechanics and the four-part
process we use at the d.school that
doesn't make great improvisation because
truly like when jazz musicians sit down
to play a song they've played before
over and over again maybe they played a
hundred times their goal is to play it
in a way they've never heard before and
how do you do that you do something
you've never done before on a regular
basis over and over again night after
night after night
well they've trained themselves to be
brilliant at improvisation improvisation
is the skill of inventing in the moment
and here's the problem it's felt like
Malcolm Gladwell's you know 10,000 hours
most people sit down in there and they
don't really practice this right you
have to practice your instrument is your
brain and you're going to control it and
it doesn't like to do this kind of
behavior it doesn't like to be free and
loose in the moment so everybody thinks
they know how to do this but actually
this this this notion of intentionally
letting go and trying to figure out how
in the moments to create something that
has never happened before that takes a
lot of practice I would estimate you
know
our work here in school takes about a
hundred hours 100 I'm teaching the first
design classes called
ME 101 visual thinking experiences in
visual thinking and it's about a hundred
hour immersion into this process of
invention in the moment through both
visualization and things like
brainstorming and mind mapping and it
takes about a hundred hours to move an
engineering student a very highly
trained very very smart Stanford
engineering student from completely
terrible to okay from novice to
competence methodology and it'll take
another ten times that before they get
to sort of an expert level of
brainstorming so you have to invest in
this because you're literally you're
building new neural pathways which allow
you to make the connections between
disparate information in a nonlinear way
that's just a fancy way of saying you
can be able to invent in the moment you
got to let go you're going to be able to
have the next word it's a yes and
process in brainstorming and it's really
hard to do them people think and one of
the reasons people say brainstorming
isn't productive is that it's actually
just really bad brainstorming
it's a mind-body problem right you've
got to be able to control how your whole
physiology works in that process most
people particularly when they're doing
this at the office or at work they're
coming from some kind of analytical part
of their day they've just come from the
budget meeting or the schedule meeting
or something and then you say hey let's
all get together and have great ideas
and it's like last you know I my brain
is not in the great idea mode it's in
the budget mode so you got to be able to
move from the analyst analysis side to
the synthesis side of your thinking and
to do that you have to warm up you
actually have to move the brain from one
state to the other we use a lot of games
that we steal from improv improv comedy
we have a fantastic classing on that
Stanford in the drama department
Patricia Ryan was a woman who created
the whole improv program we now have Dan
Klein and a bunch of other people doing
this pick up her book improv wisdom it's
not just a great book on improvisation
it's a great book on life but we have a
whole series of warm-up exercises with
stoking exercises which drive the brain
at a high
energy brain behaviors and lower the
fear of failure and allow people to
invent in the moment and when it works
it is like beautiful music you watch
these teams going in there laughing in
there and they're inventing and you know
in a five or ten minute brainstorm they
can easily generate a hundred ideas if
you're not if you're not in a
brainstorming session that is that fluid
and that productive pick up a copy of
this book learn to warm up first and and
start imagining yourself like a jazz
musician I always tell my students
creativity is just a series of behaviors
if you act like a creative person you're
indistinguishable from one so we'll just
say you are so you need to act like the
kinds of people who can generate a
hundred ideas in five minutes you know
and and it's it's a very except one that
once the transformation occurs and you
start brainstorming in this modality
the transformation is very exciting the
other thing is we took typically people
like come even if they have a good
generative brainstorm is 100 post-its on
the wall we're all done they we go okay
we're done and somebody takes a picture
of the wall as if that was going to
somehow be useful and then they're done
and then week later we go what what
happened in the brain sturms I don't
know I took a picture I haven't looked
at it yet I mean I think cell phones are
where ideas go to die they're never used
which I have to do chest right after the
brainstorm after you've done this
generative I'm not being critical we're
just having ideas then you want to do
the ideas selection grouping which is a
critical thing and they're simple the
flip that I'd offer you is don't filter
your ideas by things that can be done
filter your ideas by things that are
potential again it's changing the schema
of the sort we typically look for ideas
that are delightful that's the one that
I love to use as a filter which of the
100 ideas we have Anna board here most
cluster them into groups which group is
the most if we could create a solution
like this in my own life or for that for
the team would who would you know who
would be the most delightful solutions
to look at and and that tends to select
in a differ
fashion which gives you a different sort
of pool of ideas to work from and that's
pretty that that can be pretty
transformative and I believe that if you
know if you brainstorm well it will
transform you and if you want to
transform the team you got our other
group or your relationship or whatever
you got to transform yourself first the
data shows the novices with a poor set
up and follow through brainstorm poorly
brainstorming is is in this analogy like
a great jazz ensemble you have to expert
enough to create in the moment which
means you got to have at least 100 hours
of solid good practice you know it
doesn't it doesn't do any good to
practice poorly 400 hours if you take it
you take a golf club and swing it wildly
for a hundred hours you don't get to be
a better golfer you need a coach and you
need a trainer and you need to break it
down and need to do it right but if you
improve your brainstorming up but you'll
get a much richer set of interesting
ideas and if you choose around
interesting filters like delightful or
entertaining or weirdest you know you'll
be working with a much richer pool of
potential innovations and so if you want
to just do a couple things to make your
brain streams better warm up with an
improv game and select your ideas for
potential the final thing I want to talk
to you about in the three things you can
do to be more creative right we've
talked about getting putting yourself in
situations to get stuck changing the way
you brainstorm so you imagine yourself
as a brilliant you know fluid inventing
in the moment jazz musician I don't want
to talk about space when people come to
the workshops and they say what's the
one thing we can do when we go back to
our company what's the one thing I could
do to make myself more creative I go you
got to give yourself a creative space
space creates behavior here's a picture
of a classroom at Stanford if you would
walk into this room you would instantly
all of you have been students at one
time or another you would
instantaneously know exactly what the
behavior is required if we're doing a
poll would be the answers would be
something like sit down shut up take
notes
listen to the person at the front of the
room okay this is what we derisive lee
called the d.school the sage on stage
model of teaching
I'm going to stand in front of a
whiteboard or a chalkboard I'm going to
tell you things as you don't know you're
going to write them down and somehow or
other information knowledge will be
transferred by the way all the studies
of this method the lecture method of
teaching says it's 20 percent effective
and so frankly if I had a factory that
was making eighty percent defects I
would just shut it down and it should
just shut down Stanford and all of the
universities because they're making
eighty percent defects this isn't really
the right way to teach but it's an
example and we don't have any classrooms
like this at the d.school it's an
example of how this space imposes on you
behavior there's a very famous study
done in Stanford years ago here called
the Stanford Prison Experiment where
they made a little mock prison it was
actually just a couple of rooms in the
psychology building but because the
space was created as a coercive
environment people acted the way they
would act in a prison I would argue this
this picture of this lecture room is
pretty prison like and it's a uniformity
and lack of engagement or interaction or
radical collaboration how can you be
curious in a room like this you know how
can how can you have a bias to action in
a room like this you're not even allowed
to stand up so you know we don't have
spaces like this so the guys over at I
do which is David's big design firm
probably they are the premier design
innovation company in the world they
have a saying if you live in a cubicle
world you will think cubicle futs and I
think it I think it's true I think it's
hard to break out of an environment
which doesn't allow for the kinds of
behaviors that were we're asking you to
do so the creative spaces this is a this
is a studio over in the d.school you can
see this everything's on wheels there's
lots of graphics on the walls there's
lots of student work everywhere we also
believe that in the space that you grid
you want to have your work up all the
time so you can be constantly inspired
visually and tactile II by the work that
you're doing you want to you want
there's some studies about this in the
article in The New Yorker a while back
they talked about how space creates
innovation in a study of 36,000
scientific papers the ones ranked most
innovative
were created in collocations collocation
environments in other words the
scientists and the engineers and the
business people or whoever whatever the
innovation was they were all working
together in an innovative environment
and are are easily modified environment
seems to have a high correlation to
creativity there's a building 20 at MIT
as famous it was a building that was
built just throwing up a sort of a
prefab construction building thrown up
during the ward house some researchers
and then like any building like it was
supposed to get torn down but it never
got torn down and it was a kind of a
crappy place on campus to work so people
who were weird and different and didn't
get the prestigious labs got this lab
and that's where all the innovations for
MIT came from because in people
literally when they had a piece of
equipment and it didn't fit they just
cut a hole in the wall because it wasn't
precious stucked equipment through the
wall or they were they were smashed in
together with you know a biology
professor and his researchers were
smashed in with the mechanical
engineering professor and his
researchers and the coke the
collaboration that happened was where
the innovation occurred so space and
particularly not precious space is
critical create a war room or a project
room even if it's in your own home
create a studio all artists have studios
what our Studios their space is where
you can create make the information
about whatever you're thinking about
persistent remove all the clues about
status and who's more important and
stuff status grades hierarchy which
creates fear which defeats creativity in
the d.school
classrooms we have no visible hierarchy
there is no stage there is no front or
back to the room and then dystocia to
making the room self authoring one of
the reason we put everything on wheels
so that the space can be hacked
instantaneously if I need to work on
something big and and long on the wall I
can just push everything out of the way
and tape it to the wall if I need
something small and short I can do it
that way there's more we have a book
that a couple of guys in busy school did
Scott and Scott called make space but to
give you some examples of how to look at
your space and make it more creative in
The New Yorker article from January 2
2012 would be interesting reads my
takeaways are you know changing yourself
and becoming the creative self that is
actually inside of you isn't about you
know
things as much as it is taking things
away but it is all about changing the
behaviors if you do these three things
challenge yourself with hard problems
and get stuck more often move to the
notion that I am a musician and my mind
is my instrument and I play jazz when I
bring star and creating some spaces
which that will demand these kinds of
behaviors you will model the behavior
you want and you will act differently
and you will get different rewards
therefore from the outside world and
it'll become this virtuous cycle of
becoming more and more creative and by
the way to make any change in behavior
the psychologists take tell us it takes
at least eight weeks if you want to
change a bad habit or change a behavior
of yours it's going to take at least and
focused attention for a couple of months
you know in a new space or in something
else so you will not see the change
overnight but it is an additive process
and you will see the change occur again
and again and one of the coolest parts
about this is other people will notice
it people will come to and say what's
what's going on you seem a lot more
lively you seem a lot more curious you
seem a lot more engaging used to be and
you'll notice that they notice your your
behaviors have changed
Gandhi's quote be the change you want to
see in the world I think applies not
just globally but in fundamentally it's
an internal situation if you want to
change though the way you see the world
and the way the world sees you change
your behavior
traditional here's a question of
tradition classrooms are linear or by
design is that a yes or no question or
no I mean I will tell you that at
Stanford we've designed a number of
buildings this with the notion that we
need to accommodate some traditional
teaching but also think a little bit
more innovatively about the way we're
designing space that's one question I
think I've been on a number of design
committees that are trying to address
that concern here here so here's one
built for you innovation or creativity
is something that flows internally can
this happen under compulsion or
compulsion disrupt this notion of a
neural or organic process you know it's
interesting the question the question
poses a couple of assumptions that
not sure I necessarily agree with I
think I my my thinking lately on this is
that there is a internal compulsion for
everyone to be creative but not
everybody notices it that way perhaps as
a child the teacher told you oh you're
not an artist or you can't sing or
something something somebody somebody
shut down a natural curiosity or
creativity of yours and so humans are
pretty smart smart organisms they build
great defense mechanisms they try to
avoid pain
they try to maximize pleasure and if
you've been told at any point in time by
an authority figure who you you just
trusted intrinsically that you weren't
creative in whatever way that was
conveyed to you then the impulse for
creativity has been twisted into the
impulse for self-preservation
I don't do the behaviors that get me
exposed right don't do the behaviors
that in my organization would be laughed
at or would be laughed at in my cultural
social circle so I think once once
you've learned to manage that fear then
the natural compulsion for creativity
comes out I think most people report you
know being in a creative state is like
what psychologists tricks them behind
called a flow state you're just working
on your firing on all cylinders
everything is working you've lost a
sense of time you look up and it's 2
o'clock in the morning and you know but
but there's si or this painting or this
drawing or this cool marketing strategy
pledge you've just created is now
complete and there's something about
that that is so compelling that once you
rediscover that your relationship with
your own creativity I just think there's
a there's a drive towards it I also
think that you know you as adults
there's you know - you need creativity
of certain times in your life and other
times you just need to execute things we
need to get the job done I can't help
but think about johann sebastian bach
who is most creative period was really
having to write cantata for every sunday
mass and if you look back at his work
that's his most creative period so
something about the deliberate
of this Sunday most yeah absolutely I
mean it's well known that creative
people need deadlines nothing happens
without constraints and it's it's often
true that it's not a linear thing like
okay I've if I have to write a mass on
Sunday I'll write one gets a bit on
Monday another fifth of it on Tuesday
notice it on Wednesday in some doesn't
work that way right
I have no ideas for Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and it comes to me suddenly
and I in a burst but if you learn to
manage that process and actually learn
to give yourself your own constraints so
that you know that I want to have
something done by Sunday or I want to I
want to do this but I want to do it I
you know often in our projects and
classes will give students really really
difficult constraints like you can only
use as one square foot of cardboard to
rubber bands and a pencil design a
machine you know that can cross the pond
determine Plaza or design a machine you
know that illustrates the American dream
but the constraints create the
environment that allows creativity to
happen are there digital tools and
techniques that you see that might help
foster creativity in this new digital
age you know there's not this there's
not too much out there I'm not a fan of
most of the mind mapping software
because I think by the time you go to
the digital domain you've lost a sort of
fluidity of so drawing and I da ting
there are I think the lots of the sort
of social media tools we use a lot of
Instagram we use a lot of just you know
digital chat environments create
collaboration create instant
visualization you know sending something
to somebody a picture of what I mean or
sending a picture of my sketch is a much
more dynamic way of sharing information
and trying to explain things in text so
those things work I've got some students
working on some tools to augment
brainstorming across you know teams that
are geographically far-flung but I could
brainstorm and do things instantaneously
those those aren't quite out of the lab
yet but that we're working on that kind
of stuff
in general you know human creativity and
behavior is a pretty analog thing but we
you know we are working on taking a lot
of the core skills training around
behaviors and putting them online so
will be flipping classrooms and there is
actually an online version of the IMS
class from a few years back and we'll
probably be updating that in the future
as well so I also got clearly that if
you're going to use your cell phone make
sure to take the picture send it along
and do something with it don't want
ideas don't go to die on cellphones I
heard well-built thank you so much for a
terrific session we hope that this has
been inspiring to those of you who are
still on the line thank you for hanging
with us we will certainly send out the
additional information if you're
interested and this concludes our
webinar
we wish you a very good day wherever you
are thank you so much